on le répète depuis 30 ans mais le
constat n'a jamais été aussi bien
documenté les changements climatiques
vont non seulement transformer notre
planète mais ils sont déjà en train de
le faire comme on le voit aujourd'hui
même en Australie
sur le climat l'impact des gaz à effet
sentir
now en août dernier le GIEC annonçait
que le mercure atteindrait 1,5 degrés
au-dessus des températures moyennes sur
Terre en 2030 soit 10 ans plus tôt que
prévu aujourd'hui on enfonce le clouz
brief répète les closing
Windows tout ce qui a level future on
the planet
rappelle entre autres qu'un grand nombre
d'espèces marines de l'hémisphère sud se
déplace maintenant vers le nord à cause
du réchauffement des eaux que la survie
de jusqu'à 14 % des espèces terrestres
et menacées à court terme et que 900
millions de personnes vivent
actuellement près de zone côtière à
risque d'être inondé d'ici 2050 quelles
sont les zones du Monde qui c'est
habitable demain est-ce qu'il va falloir
envisager des déplacements ou des
transferts massif de population le
groupe d'expert estime que 15 % des
terres 21 % des eaux douces et 8 % des
océans sont protégés mais qu'il faudrait
doubler voire triplé ses chiffres pour
permettre la nature de récupérer et pour
la première fois il propose de
développer dès maintenant des stratégies
d'adaptation aux extrêmes climatiques
dans les pays du Sud d'abord parce
qu'ils sont sous équipés pour y répondre
mais aussi au nord parce que personne
n'y échappera on a trois côtes articles
Atlantiques et pacifique donc
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer fait
qu'on doit repenser les infrastructures
au niveau des canicules évidemment il
faut augmenter la canopée donc le
couvert forestier le prochain rapport du
GIEC en avril proposera des solutions
concrètes pour ralentir les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ici normalement
Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal